hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
advancing cell biology with cryo
correlative microscopy
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrutz and brought to you
by leica microsystems and
alveol to learn more visit leica
microsystems.com
and alveolab.com let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker elizabeth
wright phd
professor of biochemistry university of
wisconsin-madison
mortgage institute for research jay
yang phd and brian seibert phd
postdoctoral research associates in the
wright laboratory
and joe kim graduate student in the
wright laboratory
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr wright you may now begin your
presentation
good afternoon thank you for joining us
for today's webinar
this is the last webinar of our
three-part series on cryo-clem
during today's webinar we will discuss
how correlative cryo microscopy
is advancing cell biology
we would like to thank our sponsors and
co-organizers
like a and alveo labs we would also like
to thank lab roots for hosting this
webinar series
as mentioned my name is elizabeth wright
i am a
professor at the university of
wisconsin-madison
our research group focuses on questions
related to infectious disease and human
cell dysfunction
we also develop and use a range of
cryo-correlative imaging methods
in our research i would like to
introduce three other presenters for
this webinar
and the extended webinar series dr
jay yang is a cryo-em biophysicist in
the group
and develops light microscopy cryo-em
and cryo-clean methods and software
tools dr brian seibert is a structural
virologist on the team
he develops and uses light microscopy
cryo-em
and cryoclam workflows for virology
research
mr joseph kim is a phd student in
physical chemistry at uw-madison
he develops and uses light microscopy
cryo-em
and cryo-clem workflows for neuroscience
research
if you missed our first two webinars or
would like a refresher on their contents
in the future
you may access the material at lab roots
the first webinar
correlative cryo-imaging for cell
biology was presented on june 11
2020 in that webinar we introduced
cryo-em at uw-madison
highlighted major emphasis areas in
structural biology and connections to
cryo-em
and cryo-clem and we discussed some of
the theoretical and practical aspects of
labeling biological targets
and included research examples we also
discussed clem equipment options
and workflows including research
examples
i presented some areas for clem
technology development
and a few suggestions about resources
in the second webinar
a hands-on tutorial workflow advances
for wholesale
correlative cryo microscopy
this was presented on july 2nd 2020.
in that webinar we discussed cryo-em at
uw-madison and highlighted
aspects of cryo-em and clem we
considered best practices for cell
culture
micro patterning workflows and advanced
cryo-clem strategies
let's begin here with a brief overview
of today's webinar
i will introduce cryo-em at uw-madison
and mention some key reasons for why
cryo
and why clem from there i will discuss
cryo-clem
equipment options and workflows then we
shift
to a practical discussion of
micropatterning with the alveol primo
system
and cryoclam with the leica em cryoclin
during each of these portions i will
highlight some biological results
i will present some future areas for
clem technology development
i will then provide a few suggestions
about resources
make a few acknowledgments and point to
our previous webinar events
the right lab moved to uw-madison in
2018
to begin our next phase of work in
cryo-em structural studies of bacteria
human cells and viruses simultaneously
we set out to build
a cryo-em research center at uw-madison
in the department of biochemistry
to support the research endeavors of
investigators across the uw
madison campus regionally nationally and
internationally we have assembled a
team of the pi two staff scientists
eric and matt four post-doctoral
research associates
jay brian julian and daniel
and three graduate students joe juan
and vicky members of the group are
engaged in facility management and
technology development
research projects in the areas of
infectious disease and neuroscience
and cryo-em education we are always on
the lookout for new team members
in addition to our team we have a suite
of instrumentation to support all major
cryo-em workflows
from the basics of sample optimization
by negative stain tem
to single particle data collection and
3d map determination
we specialize in areas associated with
cryoklem
and cryoelectron tomography and have
built resources to
support studies of biological targets
from light level imaging
through cryofib scm sample milling
and cryo et data collection 3d
reconstruction
rendering and sub volume averaging
the members of the team and
instrumentation are essential for the
success
of cryo-em studies in the wright lab and
the cryo-em research center at
uw-madison
recently the nih funded four
institutions to build a national network
of cryo-electron tomography centers
uw-madison will be the central cryo-et
hub to support specimen preparation
data collection data processing and
coordination with the three other
centers
specimen preparation service centers
will be located at cu boulder
the new york structural biology center
and stanford slack
we anticipate rolling out services in
late 2021
or early 2022.
now back to cryoclam why
are researchers actively developing
strategies that use fluorescence
microscopy
correlative light and electron
microscopy and cryo-em
briefly cryo-em technologies were
pioneered to retain
specimen hydration and reduce electron
beam radiation damage to the biological
sample
while imaged in the vacuum of the
electron microscope
these advances allowed data to be
collected that could be
computationally processed to generate
native 3d structures of macromolecules
from nanometer to atomic resolution
levels
in kind fluorescence microscopy was
developed for resolving targets of
interest during the imaging
of living or fixed specimens
finally correlative light and electron
microscopy or clem technologies methods
grew from the need to define the 3d
structures of macromolecular complexes
by em
that have been spatially resolved in
biological specimens by light microscopy
in cryoklim the goal is to achieve
direct correlation data
from the specimen
as we consider the cryo-em workflow to
use so much depends really on the
biological question
what is our target an isolated
macromolecule or macromolecular complex
whole cells perturbed cells or tissue
and simultaneous to these considerations
of the biological target
selection of the technologies used for
sample preservation and imaging will
also impact the relationship between
context
and achievable resolution when we move
forward with a research project we
consider the workflow in four
phases the first is sample optimization
and preparation
the second is specimen preservation
the third is the imaging pathway
and the fourth is the computation and
data analysis
within this series of webinars we have
focused on the central pipeline for
imaging intact cells for light
microscopy
cryofluorescence microscopy and
cryoelectron tomography
truly everyone is investigating exciting
biological questions that may benefit
from light
and electron microscopy imaging however
we may not know what resources we need
for addressing these questions
and whether we should house them in our
own laboratories or use them
as part of a shared resource there are
many
options available for equipment and
decisions regarding
the systems to purchase and use depend
on your
experimental factors that are generally
determined during the initial
development of a project
and refined over the course of the
investigation
for the ideal and highly automated
cryoklem workflow
one would eat access to live cell
imaging systems
a plunge freezer a cryoklem microscope
a cryofib scm for sample thinning
and a cryotem
so how do we practically do cryoclam
in our lab we and other labs we have
developed
a cryo-clem workflow that includes
standard operating procedures in areas
that may require optimization to improve
the success rate
of cryoklem experiments for the novice
and the experienced practitioner
this workflow is conveniently color
coded to help
the investigator work through each step
and the associated steps of the process
two areas within this workflow are
called out with red and blue boxes
for two reasons first when working with
a working with a variety of cell
cultures both eukaryotic and prokaryotic
it is critical to maintain a sterile
working environment
using the appropriate environmental
controls and to use aseptic
or sterile techniques to eliminate
possible sources of sample contamination
second once samples have been plunge
frozen
it is essential to maintain samples
tools and equipment at temperatures
much lower than minus 150 degrees
celsius
to minimize specimen defectification or
contamination
in order to help individuals plan and
troubleshoot
wholesale cryo climb experiments i will
outline
a few steps within the workflow
during the process when we transition to
grid preparation there are a number of
considerations
briefly each member of your team should
have a standard set of tools and
laboratory equipment to minimize
specimen contamination
and maintain your continuity of research
we prefer to use matte tech dishes for
clem imaging experiments because they
have a glass coverslip in the bottom
that allows for periodic light
microscopy imaging
without the introduction of additional
grid handling steps
we commonly add an additional thin layer
of carbon to the grid surface to improve
substrate develop stability
and increase cell happiness depending on
the attributes of the biological target
we may use perforated or continuous
carbon films
one of the most critical steps is that
we may also add an extracellular matrix
protein across the grid
to enhance cell adhesion and spreading
at this step we may define regions of
the grid where the extracellular matrix
material is applied
and encourage ordered cell adhesion and
spreading
finally we add both fluorescent and
electron dense markers to the sample
to support correlation and image
alignment during the reconstruction
process
an area of development in our lab and
several other labs in the cryo-em
community is micro patterning
to support complex cell culturing
experiments and the improved automation
through the clem pipeline the leading
rationale for micro patterning is that
cells
be they eukaryotic or prokaryotic really
do not grow in two dimensions
or in isolation therefore technologies
can be developed to support the
expansion
of the native in-situ micro-environments
on a substrate
this will increase our capacity to
understand fundamental cell biology
and design experiments to tease out
architectural mechanical
physiological and other structural and
functional relationships
present between cells in a tissue and
organ systems
in this schematic from alveolabs we
review the basic steps in the maskless
photo patterning process first
the substrates such as an em grid or a
light microscopy coverslip
is coated with an anti-fouling agent
and then as fo and then the
photoactivatable plpp liquid
or gel agent second the user will
prepare a pattern with a basic image
creation software
the pattern can be simply a rectangular
pattern of ordered lines to complex
patterns that include
multiple geometries and possible
gradients within the pattern
the pattern is then transferred to the
leonardo software
that will control the substrate
patterning process on the microscope
third the substrate is loaded onto the
microscope platform
registered and then with uv illumination
the pattern is introduced onto the
coated substrate
the illumination process causes local
degradation of the peg polymer this
material
and the excess plpp agent is then rinsed
away
in the fourth step the user applies an
extracellular matrix material
antibodies or other biological agent
this material will remain only where the
patterned
process occurred finally
one is able to seat cells at an
appropriate density
onto the pattern substrate
at this point we recommend visiting the
alveolab website to watch a complete
video tutorial
on tem grid micro patterning in addition
there are links to several papers from
the cryo-em community
on the use of micro patterning in cell
biology
also please really reach out to the
alveolab team
and the growing user community brian and
joe
from mylab are happy to share our
experience
we hope you take the time to visit the
alveo lab website for more information
and brian and joe's experience the most
critical steps to consider
for the cells
are the design of the pattern and the
selection of the ecm material it is
important to keep the cell type in mind
in particular what is known about their
native environment
for the patterning process use a stencil
to maintain grid support and hydration
on the coverslip or madtech dish
in addition during the incubation
periods keep the grids hydrated in a
light protective container
finally how long does the process take
in our hands we are able to move through
the pattern design
to sell seating on eight grids in a
matter of five hours
brian has also been able to prepare a
batch of pattern grids and store them
for approximately a week
prior to using them in a cell culture
and imaging experiment
other groups have reported longer
storage to use times
neurons have been imaged by a wide range
of light and electron microscopy methods
studies have been performed on cells
isolated from tissue
cells and intact tissue slices and cells
of neural organoids
microscopy studies of neural cells have
advanced our understanding of basic cell
function
cell development neural cell
communication
and a wide range of neurological
diseases including
neurodegeneration the basic morphology
of a neuron is depicted in the cartoon
from left to right we have the soma
which is the main body of the neuron
that contains the nucleus
from the soma smaller dendrites extend
and branch off
the axon or nerve fiber extends from the
soma and carries nerve impulses away
from the cell body
and to the next cell beyond via the axon
terminals
that connect with the next cell's
dendrites over
the neurological synapse joe has been
working with tanner tempas
from eric dent's lab to culture mouse
cortical neurons
on em grids
in the light microscopy image on the
left we can see several neurons
their soma and the dendritic extensions
in the middle image joe has taken that
grid
plunge rose in it and image it under
cryo conditions
in the electron microscope at this em
imaging level we are able to visualize
cell bodies dendrites
and axons we are also able to correlate
light microscopy and em level images
to identify specific regions of the grid
and target certain cells or locations
on cells for higher resolution imaging
so once you have mapped out your grid
selected specific regions of interest
and identified these cells of interest
it is time to collect
tomography tilt series
a tilt series is a collection of 2d
images that are iteratively acquired
as the sample is tilted in the
microscope
images are captured at defined tilt
angles while the sample is tilted
however here we see a cryotilt series
that joe has collected of a mouse
cortical neuron
the grid is a metal mesh that supports a
perforated carbon film layer
ideally one collects images over a hole
in this carbon film
as the movie runs we are able to see
many features of the cell
that will be further revealed upon
reconstruction
after the tilt series is acquired
computational algorithms are used to
generate a three-dimensional
reconstruction
or tomogram in this movie
we are now slicing through the 3d volume
of the cell
or an extension of this cell as we look
closely we're able to identify
cell membranes a mitochondrion
microtubules vesicles and small
macromolecules and macromolecular
complexes
it is definitely a rich environment that
supports our ability to define the inner
workings of cells
in order to better understand how they
function and the impact of disease
on the cellular study state
while examining 2d images and 3d
reconstructions of cells
is very informative with those with
experience it is also valuable to render
or segment cells in a manner that makes
the information accessible for other
researchers
here joe has used the e-man 2 neural
network tools to segment
the major structural features of the
neuron
in yellow we have the mitochondrion and
light blue
the microtubules the vesicles are in
purple
and the cell membrane is gray
viewing a segmentation in 2d or 3d space
allows us to better investigate the
internal architecture of cells
and where organelles macromolecules and
membranes come together
to regulate cell function
as mentioned neurons have been imaged by
a wide range of light and electron
microscopy methods
recently investigators have begun using
micropatterning approaches with neurons
this has opened up a broad range of
research options including the capacity
to direct cell growth
options for defining neuronal cell
networks
and studies of network development and
others
of neuron cell signaling a beautiful
example
of neuron cell networks formed on a
micro pattern substrate
comes from natalie piet from the studer
lab
in bordeaux here the cells have
organized in a pattern reminiscent
of an extended computer circuit board
in a second project in the lab joe has
been culturing neurons
from other organisms including fly
larvae
on em grids this is a collaboration with
the will
willdonger lab by employing
micropatterning we are able to define
where cells
grow on the grid to support fluorescence
microscopy
and cryo-em experiments minimize their
spreading across grid bars
and foster parent patterns that support
cell spreading
and forming cell to cell contacts
in the left hand image we have a light
microscopy map of the entire
grid here in the blue channel
we are able to see the ecm matrix
pattern that joe has produced with the
primo system
it is a pattern of x's that do not
extend outside
of the carbon film areas on the grid
and the higher magnification blow-ups on
the right-hand side
we are able to view individual neurons
in green
that have seeded onto the pattern again
in blue
adhered and spread only along the ecm
coating
of this pattern
once the neurons were happily growing
along the micro pattern regions on the
em grids
joe plunge froze the samples from there
he imaged them by cryo-em at multiple
magnification levels
in the top middle panel we see the
entire grid as we did by light
microscopy at the left
and are able to pinpoint and mark
specific grid squares with pattern
neurons for closer inspection
these are the green squares in the upper
right hand panel
we identified a cell body or
soma and a single grid square and
selected portions of dendrites
for higher magnification imaging
one of those regions is shown in the
lower panel
here joe was able to identify a number
of vesicular structures
and ordered highways of microtubules
they are bound by the blue stars
further analyses are underway to learn
more about the overall
architecture of these cells and the
organelles and
macromolecules within them
as you have seen in the previous
webinars we have a robust workflow for
cryoklem studies
of cells and virus-infected cells
this workflow relies strongly on tools
from alveolabs
i.e the primo system and leica namely
the emgp
and the em cryo-clem with these tools in
hand we are developing improved routines
for better automation and correlation
between cryofluorescence microscopy
and the cryo-em data here jay
demonstrates
the steps of the basic workflow for
correlation between
cryofluorescence microscopy from the
leica
cryoclam and cryo-em data from a 300 kv
side entry microscope the data is of an
rsv-infected cell
where bias replication competent cells
are indicated in red
and the native immune immunolabeled
virus particles fluoresce
in green
so now that you have prepared your
sample imaged it by light microscopy and
retrovide it via plunge freezing or high
pressure freezing
it is time for cryofluorescence
microscopy imaging
there are many instrument options
available the selection of the system
depends on the attributes of the
particular system
as well as your biological targets we
decided upon a system that is part of a
seamless workflow
has minimal transfer steps between the
systems
and methods for handling that eliminate
possible sample damage
as well as that the imaging and
coordinate data
is readily correlatable to the electron
microscope
for our work we have had great success
with the leica em cryoclem system for
studies of bacteria
human cells and virus infected cells
one the liquid nitrogen the
glycocryoclaim
has 11 major components one the light
liquid nitrogen pump for cooling the
cryo stage
two the temperature control unit for
that regulates
pump function and monitor system
temperature
three the dm6 microscope
for a 50 x thermally isolated cryo
objective
five the cryoklim stage that supports
loading and imaging of two samples
six the overall microscope control unit
seven the stage control unit
eight the cryo transfer shuttle used for
loading grids
into the chuck and onto the cryo clem
stage
nine the fluorescent light source ten a
cmos
or other type of camera and 11 the pc
with the las
x and other software components
so you have prepared your samples loaded
them into the cryoklim transfer shuttle
and you are ready to begin clem imaging
in this and the next slide we will
review the steps associated with imaging
a single
primo micro patterned cryom grid on the
glica
cryo clem the entire process per grid
depending on grid quality target number
of regions of interest
the number of fluorescents channel is
needed may take up to one and a half
hours here we see joe at the cryo clem
imaging cells
again we perform this experiment with a
single
primo micro patterned cryo-em grid
the cryo-climb imaging took one and a
half hours
on this grid bas-2b
cells were cultured and subsequently
infected with
rsv i.e respiratory syncytial virus
the video captures screenshots of the 21
steps
of the grid mapping and imaging process
in the las x
matrix screener the first 10 steps take
approximately 20 minutes
and set up the basic imaging conditions
for the grid
in step 1 the grid template and the grid
are aligned
for the user to select
the imaging parameters such as filter
cube sets
camera exposure times and single or
multiple channels per position
in steps 2 through 4 the user sets up
the imaging parameters
for focus and selects focus positions
in steps 5 and 6 the user runs the focus
map
at the pre-selected focus positions
across the entire grid
now in steps 7 through 10 the user often
re-runs
with some manual input the focus
routines at selected positions
to fine-tune the parameters the next six
steps
will set up mosaic acquisition and
generally take about 10 minutes to
complete
in step 11 the user defines the mosaic
areas for data to be acquired in steps
12
through 15 the imaging conditions for
mosaics are refined
and may include adjustments to the
filter sets
exposure time and z stack heights
in step 16 the export parameters are
validated and adjusted
if needed during steps 17-19
the grid mosaic is acquired this process
may take
up to 40 minutes depending on the number
of channels used
height of the z-stack sampling steps
used
and areas collected
the final two steps of the cryo climb
imaging process are identi
to identify and mark registration points
over the entire grid as seen in yellow
this is step 20 and then identify
targets of interest for cryo-em data
collection
squares with the green points an object
of interest
and the blue points step 21
now at last you are finished
you may continue to the second grid or
finish the process for
a single grid save and export your data
and recover your grid for transfer to
the cryo-electron microscope
because cryoclam is complex and relies
on the need for accurate and timely
alignments and correlations to be made
between fluorescence microscopy
and electron microscopy data we
developed correlator
here is an overview of the cryo clem
workflow with correlator
and serial em this diagram showcases the
integrated feedback based alignment loop
between correlator
and serial em the dashed gray boxes
denote
the main operations performed in
correlator
the solid gray boxes surround the main
operations that are
performed with serial em
also noted are areas of overlap in the
cerelium navigator file 1
and file 2 that link correlator
and serial em purple arrows indicate
the iterative flow of the user in the
loop alignment
that is followed until accurate
correlations
are achieved
so you've made it again
you have loaded your sample into the
cryotem
you have your maps and navigator files
now
what
briefly with five screen captures from
clem
on a titan krios we will walk you
through the major correlation steps
on the previous primo micro patterned
grid
the first step is to import the cryoclin
mosaic
the image then you will import the
navigator registration points
that are noted in yellow from there
you will transfer the cryo climb image
to
and the navigator points this is
followed by the transform process
that will allow the image and the
navigator points to transfer
to the tem map the pink and red markers
now that you have a large scale map and
the points are in register
you can begin to work on finer
correlation processes
at the level of the grid square hole
and object of interest
in this cryo tem image we can see the
orientation
of the bas-2b cell along the same
trajectory
as the premo micro-patterned area
we are excited to remind you that
correlator is readily adaptable
for clem and cryoklim imaging of
virus-infected cells
mammalian cells bacteria or other
systems
in this panel we are demonstrating the
multi-faceted workflow
as applied to rsv infected cells
in panel b in the upper left hand
we see the cryo-em grid map where a
region of interest is noted with a green
box
in c we note the initial live cell
fluorescence microscopy mosaic of the
same grid
as in b with fluorescent signals
from rsv infected cells in red
the rsvf glycoprotein on the rsv
infected cells
or released particles in green
and cellular dna with the hot stain in
blue
in d we illustrate a serolium screenshot
of the cryo tem map of panel b
after it was correlated with the live
cell fluorescence microscopy
map of c and correlator
the maps for the green region of
interest squares were identified
and collected blue boxes note many
regions of interest on the entire map
panels e and g represent the full clem
workflow
that corresponds to the green region of
interest in panel d
with a live cell imaging square an e
a processed
cryofluorescence microscopy image in f
and a cryo-em map at 470x
of the region in g
and panels h and i there are
superimpositions
of the correlated correlated live cell
fluorescence
microscopy image i e and e and
h and the processed cryofluorescence
microscopy image
that's noted in f and i with the em
map and g respectively
the same regions of interest of rsv
particles were present and identified
in both fluorescence microscopy
modalities
i.e live cell imaging and cryoclam
imaging
these are noted with the matching
colored boxes
panel j presents a central region
with a thickness of 9 nanometers through
a tomogram
of rsv collected at the red boxed region
as with all areas in structural biology
many of us are looking at the future of
clem
imaging are there improvements to the
methods and technologies that will lead
to better and faster results
absolutely yes we can consider a range
of improvements
in particular we are interested in
improving substrates and cell culturing
methods
through micro patterning and
microfluidics we are also engaged
in the developing of improved automation
routines
through software and hardware advances
and as you have seen throughout the
webinar series
we have a robust workflow for cryoklim
studies of cells
and virus-infected cells this workflow
relies on tools from alveolabs
and lycomical systems namely the dmi8
microscope
with the alveol primo system mgp
and the em cryoclin with these tools in
hands
we are developing improved routines for
cell culturing
along with better automation and
correlation between cryofluorescence
microscopy
and cryo-em data
one always asks what's next
how do i begin my project and here is a
list of resources within the community
and from leica and alveo labs there are
numerous ways to connect
with cryo-em experts as a community we
are all very happy to answer your
questions
i'd like to take a moment to acknowledge
a few members of our team
historically cryo clem developments in
the group were led by sherry hampton
josh strauss rebecca dillard zunlong ki
and hong yi our latest advances at uw
madison
have been pioneered by the efforts of
jay yang brian seibert
joe kim and matt larson
we have also had wonderful support from
our colleagues at leica
louise bertrand and nancy rizzo and at
alveo labs
with aurelian duboin and serge kadura
here i have highlighted the previous
webinars in the series
they are available for viewing at any
time from the lab roots website
in addition webinars are also located on
the leica
alveolabs and cryoem lab websites
we very much thank you for your
attention today and with the other
webinars
and we will now pause for questions
thank you for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
for brian
you mentioned in your presentation that
you see the cells in appropriate density
onto the grid pattern substrate
please could you explain how this is
controlled
great question before we see the cells
on the grid we
count them and dilute them to a target
density depending on the experiment we
either
add the cells to the grids all at once
or if we're using a micro patterned grid
we add the cells just a few hundred
cells at a time
and monitor their adhesion to the
patterns with a light microscope
and once all the patterns are occupied
by cells
we stop attic cells and incubate the
grids
this does need to be optimized for each
cell type
that you want to use
thank you brian our next question here
is for joe
in cell clusters the cell the cell
connections and arrangement are critical
to overall function based on their
polarity
can micro patterning reproduce these
connections
it is entirely possible that such
connections
can be reproduced by micro patterning
there was a previous slide throughout
the presentation where a pattern while
enabled on glass
enabled an entire neural circuit to be
constructed
through a synaptic network as long as
one takes certain consideration
in the placement of specific regions of
the cell in specific patterns and
locations
it's believed that many cell to cell
interactions can be patterned
through micro patterning while also
controlling for polarity and distances
between adjacent cells
for a variety of different cell to cell
connections and interactions
all right thank you joe our next
question is for jay
in slide 32 figure f you mentioned
this is a processed image of e showing
more defined details
please could you explain what type of
processing was done
good question so actually e and f are
from different
imaging modalities e is the lifestyle
fluorescent microscopy image prior to
plunge phrasing
and it's visualized under oil immersion
objective lens at
room temperature and f is a processed
trial to an
image after the identical cells being
cloned frozen
so in our previous webinars and other
leica webinars we've been showing that
more details could be revealed
after advanced image processing tools
and then so here
the technique we're using is actually
called a small volume computational
clear
clearance implemented in the leica
thunder package
and this processing actually allows for
preservation of the pixel coordinate
position and subsequent actress
alignment
and correlative imaging so we show enf
here just to demonstrate the flexibility
and adaptability of cloudclone workflow
to other existing systems
thank you jay our next question here is
for um elizabeth let me pull it up
oh i'm sorry okay when you used
a grid box is it possible that the
important information located on the
line region of the box
is if this is occurred how do you solve
that problem
that's a great question and i think
what the person is asking is
when you have grids if the sample is
located on the grid bar
i.e the metal mesh substrate if not
please email me offline and i'll be
happy to
to answer more completely so
typically we are not imaging through
that area because
the grid bar is a metal and the electron
beam will not penetrate that area
now if you're using a combination of
stem
technologies where you could image by
scanning electron microscopy
you could reveal the surface topology of
of that particular cell or object of
interest
alternative methods are depending on how
you prepare the grid and what type of
grid substrate is there
you may use the sid milling approaches
or
even in some cases ultramicrotomy
where you could mill and remove that
metal mesh
to reveal some of the cell structure
that's a little bit more tricky
but it can be done
well thank you elizabeth our next
question here is for brian
is grid preparation and micro patterning
similar
to what you have described if using
yeast such as saccharomyces cerevisiae
that's a great question we have not done
any micro patterning
with yeast but if there is a matrix
protein or
other protein that the yeast will
preferentially adhere to
then it should be applicable to yeast or
any other cell type that has the
extracellular matrix protein
equivalent
thank you brian okay our next question
here is also for
elizabeth you use plunge freezing in
your methods
would there be an application of high
pressure freezing for somewhat larger
samples with tissues
again a really fantastic question and so
yes
absolutely so for more
conventional pipelines so in the earlier
section of the talk
we gave a workflow and on the right hand
side there were workflows where you
would transition from high pressure
freezing
to free substituted and embedded
specimens
you can also do uh samovas
processes or fiddling processes on
tissue type specimens
that would allow you to spin them down
for
imaging in the tm if you're interested
in doing vitreous work
and again we're happy to answer them
more fully offline if you would like
greater detail thank you elizabeth
our next question is for joe just a
general question he says
many cells are micrometer thick if we
cannot switch to different cell types
is there any method or trick that would
allow us to collect
cryo et data in addition to fib milling
this is a fantastic question actually
and
in addition to fib milling as well as
other sectioning processes such
as ultramicronomy um perhaps one
consideration could be
uh depending on the biological project
in mind is there a potential
morphological alteration that can occur
that would allow the cell to become
thin enough for direct imaging on the
electron microscope such as
and say as an example an application
of either a plasma transfection or a
drug that could
say induce lamellapodia like phenotypes
on that cell
that would definitely be thin enough for
electron imaging so not only are there
physical methods but there could be
creative biological methods that can
induce
direct imaging without uh in addition to
fib milling if necessary
ah thank you so much okay our next
question here
let's see we've gone to that one i lost
my place i'm sorry
okay this one is for brian
if a cryo clem is not available can
micro patterning be used as a coordinate
system for tracking cell locations
between room temperature
fluorescence microscopy and em imaging
session
yeah that's a great question and the
answer is yes it's actually something we
do
regularly you can position the cells
using micro patterning
such that you can easily determine grid
orientation
in both the fluorescent and tem map
but it's important to keep in mind that
cells may be damaged or removed during
the subsequent handling and freeze
processing
so it won't be as similar as it is with
cryoklem
okay thank you brian our next question
is for jay
um great presentation thank you i would
like to know
where and how in the workflow you are
planning to limit the transfer steps
between
vitrification systems and microscopes
uh this is a good question because uh
transferring is very risky
uh so the live cell sling imaging the
workflow we show here is prior to plunge
frozen so we don't have the
vitrification
part to worry about but the subsequent
cryoflin workflow could be conducted on
bare grids
or clipped grids so if you clip your
grip you will actually avoid
some damage during the clipping and then
do a more
accurate correlation and then right now
like a
auto grid shadow actually can be loaded
directly onto the aquilo stage
and this can actually help minimize the
eyes contamination and devitrification
or other greek handling process
so i think it's doable
thank you jay our next question is for
joe for neurons or other long cells can
micro patterning
reliably cross grid bars such that axons
in one grid square
and soma in a different grid square
could be reliably
known as a single cell
this is a fantastic question while we
have not
tested this yet we believe our micro
patterning protocol will allow longer
cells to cross the grid bars
this will be especially important for
cells with long extensions such as mouse
or rat neurons
to ensure that the axon in one grid
square and the soma in a different squid
square can be connected as a single cell
one option could be to create a buffer
zone
of unpatterned squares around the
pattern squares themselves to make sure
that no other cells can interfere with
the designated area upright cryo clean
microscopes and cryofib sem can also
confirm
that the axon in one square originates
from the soma in a different square
thank you joe our next question this is
our last question is for jay
is bringing lamellas back to the cryo
clam viable
and if so what are the downsides
uh yeah it is actually a lot of
um not a lot but quite a few labs have
success
in bringing the lamella back to the
cryoclaim system
to cross-check the milling process
because you want to know whether or not
you actually know to where you want to
be to define the end point
um i guess the big biggest concern is uh
the potential eyes contamination and the
breaking lamella
because of this multiple handling and
right now there are some tools and
labs have developed to actually put the
fluorescent
um objective lens into the aquilos
chamber
so you can actually mill while
fluorescent
um imaging this process
thank you for that answer jay and uh
thank you dr wright do you and your team
have any final comments for our audience
well thank you jen uh once again we'd
really like to thank our audience
uh lika microsystems alveo labs and lab
roots for
joining us in this webinar series
i'd like to give a special thanks to jay
brian and joe
who really provided all the data and
insights into the
topics that we've discussed and during
this series
this closes our three-part webinar
series for 2020.
these webinars are available to you at
labyrinth
and once again thank you and we wish you
a very happy holidays
and a happy new year for 2021.
thank you again dr wright dr yang dr
cyber
and mr kim for your time today and for
your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor lycro
leica microsystems and alveol for their
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you